how's it going bros my name is beautiful
and welcome to minecraft baked baked
last episode I brought back Bane's and
all of you have done nothing but sent
him hate and evil messages a bunch of
hate messages he's been crying non-stop
baked don't listen to them they love you
they do your goons back epic baked
listen it's not your fault it's not your
fault it's not your fault here eat eat
bury paint what's wrong with you Jesus
Christ beg you're starting to piss me
off
alright you start you're gonna get the
bamboo stick up your alright why don't
you love me oh you love me
you can smell the real pink is that
what's happening oh my god alright maybe
we'll try and fight yeah we'll try and
find bank what's up deep yeah yeah you
dumb you're so dumb if you're so smart
then why are you in jail huh yeah you
want some food oh yeah you'll get food
here here here's your food no no no no
I'm trying to throw eggs at you yeah oh
god damn it you will never escape do you
understand me never stay in egg land
forever
what's up like a bird was good today's a
beautiful day oh yeah forgot I brought
home that thing yeah what do you do
exactly do you do anything should we get
him out of the row yeah let's get him
out of the boat gentle now we don't want
what happened to your husband oh sorry
sorry sorry we're good Hey
are you attacking me you're not
attacking me are you we cool we cool
yeah we're cool look he's the new DJ oh
my god finally finally I've been looking
for a new DJ forever this is excellent
stay there all right or else he going to
blow he goes back to what a goddamn
idiot all right let me check in on a bit
defeat the sweet that oh you got good
reflexes I'll give you that
maybe I need to restart the friction how
do you even get oh my god that's what
happens to the Frick Shamer I keep
forgetting stop it well I need to sort
it out at some point
it's a lot of work it's a lot of work
all right spend all my time building
peepee power glorious glorious oh and I
also want to check out apparently I had
night vision on when I checked out an
Nvidia RDX so how far can you reach
basically it wasn't my fault that it
looked like crap it looked like ripe is
basically a I just murdered your friend
what are you gonna do about it nothing
because you're cowards you're all
cowards all right let's go find thanks
man you're deep we're spent oh my God
we're being invaded guys all right
preview prove your worth paint spent
deep attack yeah come on come on you go
Ike yeah bird yeah list the illest of
witness to deeper the village yeah go
team work we're killing it you're just
doing it yeah nope nope nope I said nope
alright you staying put
cool all right deep I guess this
adventures of deep and impede applied
today cuz I can't find what's his name
Sven help me help me Jesus
hey wait you need to eat bruh bright you
need to eat come on eat alright so how
can we where ask the chickens have a
gassy Bank
all right great you so maybe on top of
the meatball maybe he like fell in the
trap or something and he's stuck on the
meatball that would make sense
damn it goddamn all right kill it
[Applause]
floor Genghis ganging up on me man oh
the irony
oh god no no no all right he's fine he's
fine let's just take a moment he's fine
he's fine
look at him he's fine that's normal for
dogs to do they do this all the time
they climbed up what they're Ella Bell
gado-gado okay he's fine
they climbed up what their elevators so
gently that he's he's for God oh god I
can't look I can't look all right we're
gonna be worried we had to make him
teleport let's let's fly to pre-prepare
tower maybe he said PP tower dude hey
you are okay you're a good climber boy I
give you that I give you a good night
look at this look how cool this is yeah
kill him kill him deep deep he's gonna
he's gonna break here Burt we can't have
that
yeah yeah I keep forgetting how useless
you guys are honestly can I fly through
the hole from here watch me hit it watch
me hit it
watch me hit a watch me nae nae now
watch me oh god oh god it's fine
alright we're fine look at that look at
all all knotch
glorious creations beautiful all right
big bro are you seriously how am I gonna
find him he can't have gone that far
someone posted on reddit that he was
that they saw him
where are you Oh No Bengt I love you
banged me my banged my little being come
on oh oh it's a safe what are you what
are you you're supposed to be dead
I thought I killed you all your entire
species dead deader than dead gone
forever
in the dirt oh my god there's more it's
no reason for me to do this except it
gives me joy it really does I can't
light all right I can't believe I'm
watching this I need I can't
okay okay okay maybe this works I know
this is cheating but you guys
desperately want him back knowing that
he was found there is no bang I think I
killed him yeah it works with Sven a lot
let me go with the back to an old same
oh my god get goddamn it stop it stop
that stop it or else there will be no
rule oblique defeatist oh my god I'm
going back I don't care I'm going back
I've gone back again god damn it he was
like a father to me you would you
wouldn't understand oh my god
why does all my friends die I don't
understand I've done nothing wrong
I've done nothing wrong all right fine
you know what fine you can stay in the
pool but if you leave the pool oh my
gosh all right okay yeah yeah you're the
pool Guardian now I wouldn't have pun
that God God it's fine it's fine just
want to know if he's alive
did we not have paint on this version
that means I have to choose between
paint and bangs okay this is my work
[Music]
he loves me you're lying
this means that I have to pick between
no Panda and no paint but banked and no
Panda
that's a tough one and stupid cat out of
prison that counts as well I can't
Bertus at least here so that's good I
don't know what to do
alright paint this here that's all that
matters let's get real here and my
stupid meatball isn't blown up how dare
I call it stupid where the hell did he
go
oh my god oh he's everything he's over
there let's fence this place off I don't
want him disappearing it oh he's
swimming away from me Bengt you're safe
here you're safe with me
trust what do you see doing paint you
don't have to do you use a tacit fish
through the frickin eyes oh my god based
you're crazy you're crazy you know they
local your locomotive
alright being too safe this is so this
is all that matters let me show you
something paint follow me I think you're
gonna like this on my 5 frames per
second computer now if you say you can
there you go yeah kill them all kill
them on
yeah look at him he's fierce he never
stops yeah look at him
absolute killing machine absolute
termination look at him he oh my God
he's got so much strength that chicken
is shivering and fell yeah yeah yeah
yeah get him get him get him walk
gambler you're merging with the chicken
this is not you're an embarrassing yours
you're an embarrassing mint oh my god
you're so useless
you're the worst I've ever seen but then
what did they do to you banked yeah
that's more like yeah kill kill them all
he keeps looking at me like am i doing
good that day no you're not your own
you're an embarrassment
all right banks is back always well
that's all come on smash like on this
video for banked at least at least
there's one thing I haven't done in the
game that I'm supposed to do it's to say
I got them illegally imported in
Czechoslovakia which is getting some
honey some bees man bees month yeah let
me get W alright I think I saw one
earlier they're supposed to spawn them
with flowers
bees are why do I struggle finding
everything soon I swear where's the bee
tell me now or you will not get this
fish alright you get the fish anyway I'm
a good boy I don't hurt people out
reverse they like to kill and slaughter
animals for no reason I would never do
that
you understand where's the B I'm getting
tired of this hey goddamn your big dude
nice look at that ass boy damn look at
that B ass I'm okay with it I'm okay if
you're okay with it I'm okay with it all
right what do they do
can they mate make more beasts you want
this oh he loves it all right you're
mine you're mine you're mine
Wow minecraft you added B's
congratulations you did it yeah you're
coming with me I don't understand stop
resisting Jesus Christ
seriously what's right no no flowers we
have flowers at home trust me yeah you
know I can fly too you know you're
coming with me and you love me say it
say that you love me he said it in B
language Jesus Christ dude
all right now man come a bit honey and
stuff I don't know how it works guys
look what I find guys you will not
believe this we may have a sacrifice
panda but we got should I get Punda back
huh god dammit alright is that that Bank
yeah back to still absolutely killing
killing it alright we're all here yeah
do you be quiet you be quiet
your ancestors paid the price that you
do not want to pay huh what do you do
what does he do anything yeah pollinate
yeah do your thing you're my slave do
you understand that you will never leave
this place you will work till the day
you die and then your flexural rotten
and fertilize the earth do you
understand me he understands he said yes
in B language they collect ball pollen
and will take it back to a penis Oh Mike
you had an s and you didn't tell me oh
[Music]
my god this is the problem we don't have
any trust here
do you understand we don't have any
trouble you're dripping girl yeah keep
doing that keep doing that I like that
that sounded a lot more sexual than I
intended just so you're aware I did not
mean for that to sound like that all
right where's this home well well well
will you look at that you thought you
could escape yes did I break I broke it
I broke it Oh God all right you need
silk touch how was I supposed to know
that I don't know every I mean I know
everything about the game because I'm a
Minecraft veteran all right but I got
all right we have to sacrifice a blood
blood need to be spell I'm sorry what's
your name don't kill me please all right
okay don't blame me blame the minecraft
gods three kalsa must be sacrifice that
I say three or four yeah yeah keep
running I like it I like it dump it all
right there has to be more bees in the
trees holy crap that rhyme dude yes no
yes yeah oh no don't mock me oh well
would you look at that come here come
here where's your home hey he's spitting
on me floor gang ceiling gay oh oh oh
yes yes sure what the hell just happened
get out of thing the FBI open up all
right I got sell touch yeah did I kill
the beer is he still in the B you know
what I mean
alright okay alright you didn't see
anything no witnesses I'm sorry
no witnesses no witnesses guys you will
not believe what I just find look I
found your home yeah I did not destroy
it at all I swear alright let's put you
here go why are all my pets so useless
not you deep you're amazing Jurgen
you're incredible and spent on him but
you're the king alright go yeah go yeah
yeah now make me honeybee now make me
honey oh you're getting you like that
huh yeah look we're cooking it you're
cooking honey it's good fry trust me
guys what does it do I need help
what does it do the instruction oh you
hear hello well I don't like that I
don't like that I feel like the
conspiring against this I will have to
kill that if it comes to it I've never
been afraid to kill a pig all right
they're invincible they're invincible I
repeat their own deadly a bull can you
stop can you just stop talking for a
second please you can throw up my
sentences every time and people wonder
why I hate you you're so annoying
alright yeah
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ eat I'm sorry
I'm sorry it was a joke it was a joke
you like raw beef right what the hell do
you eat oh my god oh my god you're gonna
you're gonna take it up with PETA yeah
well I don't give a [ __ ] so go there
this is the worst episode oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'll give him fish
I'll give him a fish look I have plenty
of fish okay I'm a good boy stop judging
me all right I'm trying my best at least
I'm trying my best what do you do you do
nothing all right come out oh come on
never mind all right okay first of all I
apologize do you understand you get fish
we're cool now it's the first time I fed
you in weeks
well we should be cool all right now
we're cool we're cool you want a chair
you want to [ __ ] chair
no oh my god okay okay cool they're both
here excellent yeah pollinate and stuff
do it here I'll give you more flowers
this is working out swimmingly
everything's going great no one's died
this is a miracle and I have this stupid
chair stupid cat stupid stinky stupid
things
stupid cat seems stupid all right we are
gonna squirts now stupid cat I hate ants
you want it big you want a bigger okay
all right
you think you're so special huh you
think you're so special well you're not
I mean what's okay you are you are you
are special I'm sorry just don't call
PETA and make people unsubscribe all
right that's all I ask
come here yeah get up then you my god
you do anything else oh my god you're so
dumb all right there's just thrown
you're welcome you're welcome where's
your throne oh my god oh my god guys I'm
not doing this anymore
all right at least the beasts are
pollinating can we drink that can we
drink the honey I want I do all I wanted
honey come on give me the honey
come on give me the honey I did all this
work where you going hey hey hey give me
the honey
oh hey he's crazy
kill him same killing the realist al its
Achilles yeah oh it's a trick shots
oh you suck B oh yeah get stanked on do
the stanky legs man do the stanky leg
yeah
there's one more guys don't worry don't
worry we can keep pollinate the earth
one step at a time but anyway I'm gonna
in that episode they're like if
subscribe of course I'm so glad we we
brought back Bengt he's he is here some
somewhere I think
Bengt ear making me look like a bad
fault there yes look I knew he was there
he's loving it he's loving it he's
living his best life he's free this is a
free farm like and subscribe I upload
videos every day hit the bell
notification if you want to become a
member and get exclusive access to live
stream emojis and cool avatars and stuff
like that consider checking out all the
proceeds go to charity and that's it
hello in the world where science knows
no boundaries travel to land where no
tuber has been and explore
never-before-seen landscapes
they counter beings that are extinct
meet Mayan actors ancestors who collect
ancient items rediscover your favorite
scientifically accurate dinos what will
you create
you